>>> THANKS AGAIN FOR TAKING MY
CASE.
>> HOW COULD I NOT?
YOUR NEIGHBOR KEEPS A WILD
MONKEY IN A RESIDENTIAL
NEIGHBORHOOD AND YOU GO OVER TO
SAY "HI" AND GET MAULED.
IT'S NOT RIGHT.
>> DO YOU THINK WE'LL GET A
SETTLEMENT?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
UNLESS WE WIND UP
WITH THE WRONG JUDGE.
>> OH, YAY.
OH, YAY.
ALL RISE!
THE HONORABLE JUDGE ZENGO
PRESIDING.
>> YEP.
THAT'S A
TOUGH BREAK.
WE GOT THE MONKEY JUDGE.
>> A MONKEY JUDGE?
>> YEAH.
HE WAS APPOINTED LAST YEAR BY
THAT GOVERNOR WHO LOVES PRANKS
AND STRUGGLED WITH ADDICTION.
>> PLEASE BE SEATED.
NO ONE LOOK ME IN THE EYE.
DO NOT MAKE ANY NOISES THAT I
DON'T KNOW.
I DON'T FEEL CORNERED, SO WE CAN
BEGIN.
I HAVE DECIDED TO ALLOW CAMERAS
IN THIS COURTROOM.
HOWEVER, IF I SEE MY IMAGE IN
THE MONITOR, I WILL THINK
IT IS A RIVAL MONKEY AND I WILL
COMPLETELY LOSE IT.
NOW, ALSO, LET THE RECORD SHOW
THAT I AM ALREADY VERY CLOSE TO
COMPLETELY LOSIN
IN THE BLUE WITH THE GRAY.
PROCEED.
>> THANK YOU, YOUR HONOR.
MY CLIENT WENT OVER TO SAY
"HELLO" TO THE DEFENDANT AND HIS
PET MONKEY, GUMMO.
>> NO GUMMO.
>> WHAT?
>> TENGO.
>> YEAH.
I KNOW.
I'M TALKING ABOUT A DIFFERENT
MONKEY.
>> YEAH, YEAH.
NO GUMMO.
TENGO.
>> SHOULD I KEEP GOING?
>> YEAH.
BUT I'M GOT TO THROW A LITTLE
SAND TO SHOW DOMINANCE.
>> ALL RIGHT.
OKAY.
SO MY CLIENT WAS AT THE
DEFENDANT'S HOUSE WHEN OUT OF
NOWHERE, HIS PET MONKEY GRABBED
HER HAT AND --
>> WHOA, WHOA, WHOA, WHOA, WHOA,
WHOA.
WAS IT THE SAME HAT YOU NORMALLY
WEAR, OR WAS IT ANY DIFFERENT?
>> WELL, NORMALLY, I WEAR AN
ORANGE BUCKET HAT, AND THIS
TIME, I HAD ON A GREEN BASEBALL
CAP.
>> LET ME GET THIS STRAIGHT, YOU
WALKED UP TO THIS MONKEY AS A
DIFFERENT SHAPE AND YOU
EXPECTED, WHAT, HIM TO JUST BE
COOL WITH THAT?
FOR YOU TO NOT FEEL HIS INSANE
BREATH ON YOUR FACE WHILE HE
BROKE ALL THE BONES IN YOUR BODY
WITH THE STRENGTH OF 30 MEN.
>> WELL, HE'S IN A HANGING MOOD
TODAY.
>> ARE YOU SURE?
HE'S SMILING.
>> NO, HE'S BARING HIS TEETH.
>> IT'S HOPELESS.
SO WHO CAN REASON WITH A JUDGE
LIKE THIS?
>> MAY THE DEFENSE APPROACH THE
BENCH IN A SLOW, DELIBERATE WAY
HOLDING A BIRTHDAY CAKE?
>> THE COURT RECOGNIZES THE
SHAPE HE NORMALLY ASSOCIATES
WITH TREATS.
>> AS I APPROACH, YOUR HONOR,
I'D LIKE TO NOTIFY THE COURT
THAT I AM WEARING PERFUME, BUT I
AM NOT FRUIT.
>> THE COURT APPRECIATES THE
CLARIFICATION.
I WILL TAKE THIS CAKE, AND I
WILL PLACE IT IN MY PILE OF
SHREDDED NEWSPAPER.
AND I WILL ALSO TAKE THIS SHINY
THING.
LET THE RECORD SHOW THAT THIS
SHINY
THING WAS HIS AND NOW IT'S MINE.
AND IT GOES IN THE NEWSPAPER
WITH THE CAKE, SO NOW I HAVE WON
MANY THINGS AND I KNOW VISUALLY
WHAT I HAVE.
>> YOU ARE THE ALPHA.
>> YES.
>> OBJECTION!
YOUR HONOR, IT IS OBVIOUS THAT
YOU'RE FAVORING THE DEFENSE.
>> THAT IS RIDICULOUS.
>> YOUR HONOR?
I LOVE JUDGE.
>> I LOVE YOU.
>> I LOVE JUDGE.
>> YOU ARE BABY.
JUDGE LOVE BABY.
BRING JUDGE BABY.
JUDGE LOVE YOU.
JUDGE FAVOR DEFENSE.
>> COME ON!
>> YEAH.
WE MOVE TO REQUEST A NEW JUDGE.
>> ARE YOU SUGGESTING THAT I'M
NOT COMPETENT?
TENGO MADE THESE PIECES MATCH.
SURE IT WAS A BIT OF TRIAL AND
ERROR, BUT I DID IT.
I WON THE JUTE.
I'M GETTING TIRED AND I FEEL
SLIGHTLY CORNERED AND THIS IS
ALL GETTING SO, SO DANGEROUS.
SO I'M
JUST GOING TO DISMISS THE
ENTIRE --
>> WAIT, WAIT, WAIT.
I WOULD LIKE TO CALL A SURPRISE
WITNESS.
>> UNLESS THAT SURPRISE WITNESS
IS A RATTY OLD STUFFED ANIMAL
FOR ME TO VIOLATE, I ASSURE YOU
THE COURT IS NOT INTERESTED IN
BEING STARTLED.
>> WELL, I GOT SOME GOOD NEWS
FOR YOU, JUDGE.
>> THAT SIDE WINS.
THAT SIDE WINS.
>>> NEXT ON "MONKEY JUDGE,"
A PUBLIC URINATOR MARKED THE
WRONG TERRITORY GETS THE MAXIMUM
PENALTY.
IT IS RIPPED CLEAN OFF OF HIS
BODY.
MONKEY JUDGE.